through a wide range of mediums art has
given us a way to communicate when
regular conversation won't suffice a way
of sharing our perspectives behaviors
experiences emotions and sufferings
trying to find purpose in it all and
ideally help us stay a little more sane
and connected in this strange chaotic
world every so many years the world
seemingly hits a period of a rapid
development in which its conditions
change so significantly generations but
a couple decades apart can barely
recognize each other over the past few
decades arguably the world hit one of if
not its singular greatest and most
significant growth period ever the age
of the Internet with the creation and
commonplace use of the Internet an
entirely new condition of the world
would unfold the modern person would now
have new interests new behaviors new
perspectives and new problems access to
constant information has flooded the
individual instant gratification is now
the standard attention spans have
dropped to an extreme low meaning and
order is increasingly subjective and
difficult to find the individual
especially that of slightly younger
generations has now left somewhat
disoriented as they leave the trail
through the uncharted territories of a
new virtually integrated landscape this
new order of the world has countless
effects on our experiences of life many
of which are being studied and discussed
one area however that has rarely talked
about yet especially interesting is how
we have adapted to express and share
meaning through media and art art does
and has always withheld a fairly loose
interpretable definition that allows it
to move in a constantly evolving world
and still remain relevant and effective
a generally standard definition of art
is the use of creative imagination to
produce work that expresses certain
meanings and ideas typically with the
intention of aesthetic beauty and or
emotional potency this definition leaves
a good amount up to the individual it's
almost as if art's definition is a bit
of an artwork itself however arguably
what makes something art is less about
what it is and more about what it does
and how it interacts with the world
around it traditionally or has promoted
the good aspects of life and humanity
pointed out and often ridiculed the bad
and expressed the funny weird somber and
often dark realities we all share but
rarely talk about arguably art is art so
long as its reason for being art can be
properly context to
or defended by either the creator or
consumer and that's what we're going to
do here for a strange newly developing
art form within the 21st century known
as memes admittedly right off the bat it
might sound foolish to consider or
discuss memes with any level of
seriousness to hold a crude image with
text on it next to that of a beautifully
constructed painting might perhaps sound
like an insulting Lee far reach and by
no means does this essay intended to
spread it the beauty and talent found in
any work of art however it does intend
to say that the nature of art permits
such a claim and in such a claim
interesting insight into our weirdly
changing modern world can be found
rewind about a century to the early
1900's Marcel Duchamp was an artist
associated with the dadaism movement
which was a movement of art that
expressed the early idea that the world
is without centralized reason but rather
it is an absurd in a rational world in
1917 Duchamp created an art piece called
fountain which was essentially just a
urinal he purchased from a plumbing
store at first it was rejected when he
attempted to exhibit it as art but
sometime after it would become accepted
and redeemed as an ingenious and highly
influential piece of its time in this
piece
Duchamp begged the question of what art
could be and whether or not it had to be
made by the artist or if it could be
merely a recontextualization or addition
to what already existed fast forward a
few decades the movement of pop art
would take form in the US and UK during
the late 1950s in response to the lack
of cultural relevance that traditional
Fine Arts had in the newly changing
post-world War two ERA in similar
respects to the Dada is a movement the
pop art movement made art out of simple
everyday objects or famous figures found
within culture pop art borrowed objects
and people from essentially any source
recontextualize them and then
distributed them as an accessible piece
of art for everyone to take part in on a
mass scale bridging the gap between high
and low art showcasing the Wonder value
humor foolishness and relatability that
can be found and shared in everyday life
it is fair to argue that in many ways
memes follow this idea like Dada art pop
art and several other art forms of
recent history memes make use of
everyday objects and people in culture
these items and people are then
recontextualized and distributed freely
across the internet for anyone and
everyone to partake in and
share personal meaning relevance and
experience through in a postmodern
culture where meaning is derived
increasingly from individual experience
focused through and on to the Internet
we are perhaps experiencing a sort of
strange development of a postmodern
digital art based on shared
participation a reasonably current and
standard definition of memes are an
element of culture passed from person to
person
with the aim of conveying a particular
phenomenon theme or meaning specifically
through the internet over the last
couple decades memes have emerged out of
increasing internet use and
participation
what started as media shared on message
boards or more secluded corners of the
Internet would begin to spill over into
the commonplace of culture as social
medias would begin to unfold around the
year 2004 as a result memes began to
acquire a factor of general relatability
and intrinsic social value mean formats
known as rage comics image macros and me
IRL x' shared sentiments about personal
experience and ideas related to modern
life in most cases memes would contain a
visual image video or gif which would
indicate a type of commentary theme idea
or phenomenon associated today a
plethora of meme formats characters and
means of distribution come in and out of
popularity as they permeate across the
internet and into culture memes all have
their own touch but remained
fundamentally the same an expression of
ideas experiences and phenomena through
media just like that of art so who cares
why does this development of memes
matter or have any relevance well it's
clear that the modern world has created
an entirely new condition for the
individual we are becoming increasingly
addicted to the Internet and social
media and consequently share in the
problems that the Internet has dealt us
generally we now have an artificially
modified sense of connection and
sociability making us feel somewhat
alienated from the world and the people
around us we are hyper aware of the
conditions of the world and thus find it
rather chaotic absurd and void of any
clear meaning we share in an increasing
sadness anxiety and aimlessness and we
have less patience for things that don't
give us the point within a fairly short
amount of time making it harder and less
appealing to engage in things of long
form
arguably memes are but another evolution
and offshoot of art that serves to
satisfy our inherent and remaining human
need to share Express and derive
connection from our problems experiences
idiosyncrasies and perspectives in a
world where it is increasingly hard to
do so through traditional methods like
art movements of the past memes are a
reflection of the modern world's
conditions through no fault of our own
the use of Internet and social media has
rendered us wanting things faster easier
and more direct than ever essentially
memes are art without the mystique and
without the barrier to entry where
instead of hiding the point it literally
writes it on itself where instead of
requiring aesthetics or traditional
craft it merely requires some amount of
honesty humor and access to the Internet
where instead of an exclusivity in the
sharing of media on a mass scale just
about anyone can participate in
experience moments of Fame in virality
in 1968 world-famous pop artist Andy
Warhol accurately predicted this one
saying in the future everybody will be
world famous for 15 minutes like art of
the past meme serve to provide us with a
conduit or connection point through
which we can engage in and share our
cultural and human experiences in a way
that is creative digestible and honest
like art memes can show us the absurdity
and funniness of our existence the
things we should pay attention to the
things we should critique about
ourselves in our culture and how foolish
interesting dark beautiful confused
scared and similar we often are and even
the simplest components of our daily
life it's important to recognize that
it's not as if traditional art has been
replaced or removed by any stretch art
of all forms remains popular valuable
and enjoyed by a great many as it should
be higher art continues to hold them a
steek and aesthetic beauty that means of
course lack entirely but it is also
important to recognize that perhaps
memes are becoming increasingly relevant
and telling about the conditions of
media art and modern life however silly
or trivial it may seem every meme is a
little window into today's world an
expression of anger frustration
confusion sadness hopefulness and humor
that reflects what is happening in the
internet world that exists around it
just how art of the past is look back on
and studied in order to understand the
Associated historical errors this
current internet age will almost
certainly be
studied and understood through websites
social media platforms YouTube channels
and memes writers will be video
essayists and bloggers celebrities will
be Instagram celebrities filmmakers will
be YouTube creators movements and
cultural phenomena will be understood
through viral videos prevailing meme
characters popular hashtags and so on
what are now mostly seen as foolish
jokes videos characters images or trends
will at some point carry social cultural
insight into how the world responded
when the internet first started to
envelop life and how we attempted to
stay connected reflective and human
within it
[Music]